hello mr. Albert I'm Alice liang shuang
from Malaysia I have something to ask
you do you have to sacrifice anything in
order to achieve what you are today and
if you did I do regret it thank you very
much a good question and personal
equation so I I do not think that I had
to sacrifice a lot of things I should i
guess that have been present in addition
to present not only in the lab but also
in my family life i add also i read many
books i did was a lot of sport or see
during my life rugby at the beginning
windsurfing now and so I have know the
feeling that I get to sucker you
sacrifice out of things maybe I have
been a little more present in my family
life but for several things I relied on
my wife may be the only thing that maybe
I sacrifice is is obtaining a lot of
money in becoming very rich that is not
generally what we can obtain when you
are doing only science and research